when it comes to staying young it seems
like the stars have all the secrets so
we teamed up with celebrity makeup
artist Mellie Ron Cal and Olay up your
skincare game what are some skin and
beauty secrets that you give that we can
implement at home to take better care of
our skin hydration hydration hydration
all day never go to sleep without taking
off your makeup literally take off every
stitch of makeup and moisturize those
two things super important and then
honey beauty sleep hit the hay and
you're good so tell us about this
dynamic duo of a skincare routine malli
I love the fact that the Olay Regenerist
cream cleanser deeply cleans the skin
which is super important and then of
course the retinol 24 moisturizer which
I love because it moisturizes for 24
hours which honey let me tell you in
these days we need that moisture look at
how it literally just sinks into the
skin it's got vitamin b3 and missing all
a special retinoid complex so here can
we get these products really you can
find all these products and more at Olay
com
[Music]